steamed eight pudding with a glorious
butterscotch sauce
they weren't cool desserts on those days
were they norris puddings puddings now
i'm gonna sieve the flour would you i'll
chop here sean chop those dates please
that was a favorite wasn't it amazing
sew it in
okay but it was almost like an
old-fashioned dessert wasn't the theme
and everything was sort of steamed you
had jam really poorly
so the zest the orange makes that really
nice and fragrant sort of helps cut that
richness to the suit
okay yeah
brown sugar in
this is such an easy recipe
yes looks fantastic on the table
and then treacle
cheek it lin
look at that
there's something quite
magical about a spoonful of treacle can
you add them in there please
thank you they'll do and crack an egg
lightly whisk it and mix that into the
milk
if i pour in the egg and the milk would
you give that little mix up please yep
thank you
nice
nice and slow
don't go too fast
you see i always used to think that it
was an old-fashioned desert steamed
pudding do you ever remember me
tumbling around your knees trying to
sort of get in there yeah so you like to
lick the ball didn't you all the time
now
lightly grease
the mold you're always willing to help
but not with washing up some things
never cheat i think i was allergic to
the soap how was your excuse
kids will enjoy this tonight won't they
uh delicious
paper that goes on so the secret behind
the parchment paper is to keep that nice
and tight tight yep
there we are
good yeah oh hey push my hand
tightly cover with foil and place in a
pan of water and let it steam for around
two hours with a lid on
are you going to wash up cord
just for once wash up mr ram oh dear
goodness
do you like that smash
mom you handed it to me and you dropped
it come on
whilst mom forces me to break the habit
of a lifetime dude that's the thought
you're washing up it does that to you
here's how to make an amazing
butterscotch sauce to serve with a
pudding
add butter into a pan
brown sugar
golden syrup
and a pinch of salt
and vanilla seeds
melt and combine over a medium heat
stir in the cream and simmer until
thickened
that's the taste of my childhood inner
jug right there and it will keep in the
fridge for a week
[Music]
right homework done yep beef juice
chewing stewing let's get on with our
delicious hearty pet art i've been
looking forward to this
you and i chef i'm going to prep the
pears so if you peel
i'll top and tail
into quarters pears go soft in the oven
very very quickly so we're going to put
them on a tart you'll need to leave them
whole half or in quarter
what's that in there
ginger that's right a stem ginger so you
stem ginger and fresh ginger
next add your stem ginger a little of
the stem ginger syrup good girl and some
brown sugar to your quartered pears
and then just grab some fresh ginger off
you go so it's a bit of a um different
one to grate this because it doesn't
really come through like the cheese no
i'm gonna make that a little bit zesty
now we've got some lemons some lemon
zest in there
right what we need to do now is give
that
a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff where you make it so easy to
do
so give me your finger
that's my center point i want you to get
the pears going around
like that a really nice circle
it's difficult isn't it because the
pears keep on sliding all over the place
yeah
so egg wash the outside and i'm going to
show you a little trick
so you lift that up so the egg wash
acting like a bit of a glue that's right
crimple this with our finger
and the paste reforms this nice little
shelf
like a little money bag are you going to
do anything with the spare pears oh yeah
you start building that up then you see
we've got the fresh ginger
and those nice little bits of stem
ginger
let me go around mike with your glue
we might glue just on top tilly's last
job is to give our tart a good dusting
of icing sugar so that caramelizes it
and colors the pears beautifully it's a
bit like snow isn't it now that glaze is
a pastry so the pastry has this really
nice shine on there as well finally the
lemon on top
and then put that there
180 and in she goes
our pet art has had 35 minutes in the
oven
look at that baby
that looks good
would you like me to start dusting yes
please
nice and gently all the way around good
girl
little taps
the others are gonna love this it looks
a bit like a snowy cake doesn't it good
job
now very carefully carry that
to the table
how nice does that look
delicious okay i'll check on the
dumplings a rich and zingy pear and
ginger galette
next up dessert delicious poached pears
i love pizza ready so we're gonna poach
them with a little bit of chili
chili
never heard of that a little bit of
saffron no
no
no pan on
take off a little slice like that so
they stand up nicely and then peel
okay then and then the chili you hold
that up and just go down yep
through
and open that up okay into the water
seeds in as well
a little bit of chilli
water and sugar
what are they holes
saffron is expensive but you only need
the tiniest little bit
a little pinch to make that water go
light and golden star in these how comes
the chinese you've like sliced it at the
end and it's not put in whole i want all
that flavour coming out of the chili
we're going to make
the most amazing star in east dust sorry
stars dust
should get your star nice in there
seed
up and then
in
see all those little seeds yeah
and then
you start grinding
a little teaspoon of ginger give it a
nice mix thank you meg and that's gonna
dust the top of the pears once they're
cooked
ryan get your pears
drop them in there
and that's what we're going to sprinkle
mmm
ginger that's darwinis wow the rice is
that
very good
that's lovely isn't it so once they're
cooked
cool down sprinkle that over the top
right have you guys got homework yes see
you guys come back shortly thank you
turn that down and let them fall
okay bye thank you guys bye
after an eight minute simmer our pears
should be ready
now just get your knife on put the knife
through and see how easy the knife is
so that means they're soft and cooked
now you can leave them in that overnight
two or three days all right and they
just get darker
and more beautiful
the good thing about the cooking liquor
is that you don't throw that away
because you can use that again for
re-poaching
beautiful
i mean they look impressive they smell
delicious don't they
[Music]
look at the colors nice lovely isn't it
those are an amazing one
and just
smells delicious
and then take your little
star and east dust
and just
dust
over
you